ABBY CAREY: Cloud Code
is a set of extensions
for the most popular
development tools
in the market, the
JetBrains family of IDEs,
such as IntelliJ and
Visual Studio Code.
In this video, we'll cover the
navigation and capabilities
of Cloud Code using
the VS Code version.
Cloud Code speeds
up your development
by streamlining common workflows
for Python, Go, Node.js,
and Java applications,
merging non-trivial tasks
into a simple user
interface right in your IDE.
This means no more switching
between your command line,
Cloud Console, and code editor.
Tasks, like going through
the loop of building,
pushing, deploying, and
debugging your application,
can be both burdensome
and error-prone.
Cloud Code handles that for you.
A key goal of Cloud Code is to
enable continuous development
by automating processes.
For example, you can rapidly
iterate on a live Kubernetes
cluster or add a Google
Cloud API to your application
from your IDE.
The first thing you'll notice
when you installed Cloud Code
is the Welcome page.
This provides a summary of
the key supported features
and also has a direct link to
creating a new project from one
of our starter templates.
Let's take a look at what Cloud
Code adds to the VS Code UI.
A few icons have been added
to the VS Code activity bar.
Each icon focuses on a separate
task within Cloud Code.
If a certain task doesn't
apply to your workflow,
you can hide it by
right-clicking it and selecting
Hide.
There's also the addition of
the Cloud Code status bar,
seen at the bottom of VS Code.
From here, you can
access quick actions,
like running and creating
a new application.
Cloud Code commands
have also been
added to the command palette.
You can access them by pressing
Command-Shift-P and typing
in Cloud Code.
Let's take a look at the
workflows Cloud Code supports.
First, we have Cloud
Code for Kubernetes.
I'll create a new Kubernetes
app using one of the templates.
Cloud Code lets you run,
debug, and view the logs
of your Kubernetes apps.
This app is ready to go, so
let's try running and debugging
it.
To deploy this app,
all I need to do
is click the Cloud
Code status bar
and select Run on Kubernetes.
Once the deployment is
finished, click the link
from the log to view
your app running
on your local
Kubernetes cluster.
To debug your app, view your
code and place a breakpoint.
Go back to the status bar and
select Debug on Kubernetes.
Once you view your app and
trigger the breakpoint,
VS Code's debugger
activates, allowing
you to step through your code.
If we head to the Cloud
Code for Kubernetes view,
you'll find the
Kubernetes Explorer.
The Kubernetes Explorer lets
you visualize all the resources
within your cluster.
You can see information like
the IP address of your services
and the ports they use.
This means that you don't have
to remember all the core CLI
commands to find this info.
Right-clicking on Resources
provides contextual links
for actions, such as
viewing the logs from a pod
to opening a connected terminal,
all from within VS Code.
You can also create a
new cluster from here.
Next, there's Cloud
Code for Cloud Run.
Cloud Run is our fully
managed serverless product
with auto-scaling
that scales down to 0.
As you can see, my Google
Cloud project already
has a couple Cloud Run
services that are displayed
in the Cloud Run Explorer.
With Cloud Code, you can
deploy a new containerized app
to Cloud Run and view the logs
for your Cloud Run services.
You can also test
things out locally
before you deploy by running and
debugging your service on Cloud
Code's Cloud Run emulator.
Finally, there's Cloud APIs.
All Google Cloud
APIs are listed here.
If you select an API, you're
able to quickly enable
it and follow the provided
install instructions.
After that, you're ready to
use it with your application.
YAML authoring assistance is
another pillar of Cloud Code.
Cloud Code supports a number
of configuration files,
including Kubernetes resources
like Config Connector and Cloud
Build configurations.
It also supports over 300
custom resource definitions.
Here's a quick example of what
YAML authoring assistance looks
like for a Kubernetes
config file.
By pressing Control-Space,
I get a variety of snippets
to pick from.
After picking one, I can
tab through the sections
I need to fill in.
By pressing Control-Space
again, I get suggestions.
Linting catches syntax
errors, and hovering
over configurations provides
inline documentation.
In conclusion,
Cloud Code is a tool
that speeds up non-trivial,
tedious tasks when developing
Cloud native applications.
It also reduces friction when
creating YAML configuration
files.
To learn more about what
you can do with Cloud Code,
head to this link.
Also check out the description
below for more resources.
We'll go over other
scenarios in future videos.
Until next time.